其他人：好
Others: Okay.
Tasha: 喝吗喝
Tasha: Want to drink it?
Jake:喝呵呵
Jake: Drink, haha.
Tasha: 呵呵加冰块吗
Tasha: Haha, do you want ice with that?
Tasha: 加的话自己帮我也拿一下
Tasha: If you do, grab some for me too.
Jake:在哪里好子郎
Jake: Where is it? Xiao Zilang?
Jake:喝吧
Jake: Drink it.
Jake:喝
Jake: Drink.
Jake:不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Tasha: 喝吗
Tasha: Drink?
Tasha: 加冰块吗
Tasha: Ice?
Tasha: 我怎么记得我开过口啊
Tasha: How do I remember opening it?
Jake:我要把它给弄碎啊
Jake: I need to crush it.
Jake:他太大了
Jake: It's too big.
Jake:这么大
Jake: This big.
Jake:注水
Jake: Add water.
Tasha: 到了你不喝
Tasha: It's ready, you're not drinking?
Tasha: 罪大恶极
Tasha: That's a crime.
Jake:没没不喝
Jake: No, not drinking.
Jake:没不喝你们先挑
Jake: No, not drinking, you guys pick first.
其他人：你在下面吃吗
Others: Are you eating downstairs?
Jake:在下面吃
Jake: Eating downstairs.
Jake:在下面吃还是在上面吃
Jake: Eating downstairs or upstairs?
Jake:可以在上面吃
Jake: You can eat upstairs.
Jake:当盒饭吃
Jake: Like a boxed meal.
Jake:我看要在外面吃得了
Jake: I think it's better to eat outside.
Jake:哦确实
Jake: Oh, for sure.
Tasha: 在上面还是在下面都可以开空调
Tasha: You can turn on the air conditioning whether you're upstairs or downstairs.
Jake:在上面吃
Jake: Eat upstairs.
Jake:在下面吃
Jake: Eat downstairs.
Jake:你是你是吃
Jake: You, you are eating.
其他人：上面不是比较干净吗
Others: Isn't it cleaner upstairs?
Jake:好吧
Jake: Okay.
其他人：参观了非常的完美
Others: The tour was perfect.
Tasha: 谢谢你
Tasha: Thank you.
Tasha: 你要去看吗
Tasha: Do you want to take a look?
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
其他人：非常的厉害
Others: Very impressive.
Jake:确实厉害
Jake: Definitely impressive.
Jake:这整了半个小时
Jake: It took half an hour.
Jake:整完一个小时
Jake: Took a whole hour.
其他人：我还没加你的微信
Others: I haven't added your WeChat yet.
Tasha: 哦没事我来加你姐姐
Tasha: Oh, no worries, I'll add you on my sister's.
其他人：你子啊那个群里面就是那个
Others: You're in that group, right? The ego group.
Tasha: 嗯嗯ego群
Tasha: Yeah, the ego group.
Tasha: 进吧
Tasha: Come in.
其他人：完全完全不一样了
Others: It's completely different now.
Tasha: 谢谢
Tasha: Thanks.
其他人：这些都是你补充的
Others: Did you add all this yourself?
Tasha: 买的
Tasha: Bought it.
Shure: 妈的你都不知道还有多少个快递
Shure: Damn, you have no idea how many packages there are.
Tasha: 你自己来看嘛
Tasha: See for yourself.
Tasha: 你来看来看来看
Tasha: Come and see, come and see.
Tasha: 谢哥谢哥
Tasha: Thank you, thank you.
Tasha: 挑一件走
Tasha: Pick one to take.
其他人：ok
Others: Okay.
其他人：你把那Jelly cat挑走
Others: Take that Jellycat.
其他人：这就是我未来的梦想啊
Others: This is my future dream.
Tasha: 你未来的梦想啊
Tasha: Your future dream?
其他人： 就是一个自己
Others: Just to have my own...
其他人：这Jelly cat吧
Others: This Jellycat, right?
Tasha: 就这个
Tasha: This one.
Tasha: 这不是啊
Tasha: Not this one.
Tasha: 哪有这么多
Tasha: How can there be so many?
Tasha: 这一一长串啊
Tasha: It's a whole long string.
Tasha: 这送给你女朋友
Tasha: This is for your girlfriend.
Tasha: 真的我跟你说这个
Tasha: Really, I'm telling you.
其他人：OK没关系
Others: OK, no problem.
其他人：谢谢姐谢谢姐
Others: Thanks, sis, thanks.
其他人：过过几天来拿
Others: Come back in a few days to pick it up.
Tasha: 还挺可爱的吧
Tasha: It's pretty cute, right?
Tasha: 装饰完了
Tasha: All decorated.
Alice:真可爱
Alice: So cute!
其他人：你知道那100左右一个花了多少钱
Others: Do you know how much each of those flowers cost, around 100?
其他人：这什么东西啊
Others: What is this thing?
其他人： 花多少钱
Others: How much did it cost?
Shure: （歌词）难忘今宵
Shure: (Lyrics) Unforgettable Tonight.
Tasha: 什么时候吃饭
Tasha: When are we eating?
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
其他人：天热死了
Others: It's so hot!
其他人：好热呀
Others: So hot!
Tasha: 你后面去三亚吗
Tasha: Are you going to Sanya later?
Tasha: v too现在不是处理数据吗
Tasha: Isn't V Too dealing with the data now?
Tasha: 还是拍v too
Tasha: Or shooting V Too?
Tasha: 真的呀
Tasha: Really?
其他人：啊真的吗
Others: Ah, really?
其他人：他得他得他
Others: He must, he must.
其他人：他要是愿意为我报销的话
Others: If he's willing to reimburse me,
其他人：我会义无反顾
Others: I will go without hesitation.
其他人：勇往直前
Others: Move forward bravely.
Tasha: 这么好
Tasha: So nice.
Tasha: 你们清华植物多吗
Tasha: Do you have a lot of plants at Tsinghua?
其他人：清华的话
Others: At Tsinghua,
其他人：嗯还行
Others: Hmm, it's okay.
Tasha: 做一个数据调查
Tasha: Doing a data survey.
其他人：还行
Others: It's okay.
其他人：因为他他的西点就是非主要的教育区
Others: Because his West Point is not the main education area.
其他人：那边是原来圆明园的
Others: It used to be the Old Summer Palace.
Tasha: 那现在进去要预约吗
Tasha: Do you need to make a reservation to get in now?
其他人：就是你先在他的公众号预约
Others: You need to make a reservation on their WeChat public account first.
Tasha: 啊这么严格
Tasha: Ah, so strict.
其他人：好像每天要限额吧
Others: I think there's a daily limit.
其他人：就是今天开7天后
Others: You can book 7 days in advance.
其他人：但其实周中一般都约不满
Others: But usually it's not fully booked during weekdays.
Tasha: 啊行
Tasha: Ah, okay.
其他人：但是五一肯定早满了
Others: But May Day is definitely fully booked.
Tasha: 谁五一去啊
Tasha: Who's going on May Day?
Tasha: 我肯定不去
Tasha: I definitely won't go.
其他人：你就遥遥领先了
Others: You'll be way ahead.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 到时候我咨询咨询你
Tasha: I'll ask you for advice then.
Tasha: 哪里植物多
Tasha: Where are there more plants?
其他人：你就从西门进西边植物多
Others: Just enter from the west gate, there are more plants in the west.
其他人：西边是原来圆圆的园林
Others: The west side used to be a round garden.
其他人：小园林
Others: A small garden.
Tasha: 写篇小论文然后再搞个毕设毕业
Tasha: Write a small paper and then do a graduation project to graduate.
其他人：好毕设
Others: Good graduation project.
其他人：靠这是我毕设
Others: Damn, this is my graduation project.
其他人：平板还没写
Others: I haven't written the tablet yet.
其他人：哇差MD翻译
Others: Wow, MD translation.
其他人：please translate this paragraph into Chinese
Others: Please translate this paragraph into Chinese.
Tasha: chatgpt写歌还可好听了
Tasha: ChatGPT writes really good songs.
其他人：你猜微信能写歌吗
Others: Guess if WeChat can write songs?
Tasha: 不知道啊杨老板
Tasha: I don't know, Jake.
其他人：苏诺AI哦
Others: It's Suno AI.
其他人：杨老板现在可能在赶赶DDL
Others: Jake might be rushing to meet a deadline now.
Tasha: 啊苏诺
Tasha: Ah, Suno.
Tasha: 赶什么
Tasha: Rushing for what?
其他人：发布会的DDL
Others: The deadline for the press conference.
Tasha: 是吗杨老板
Tasha: Really, Jake?
Tasha: 杨老板你为什么不出来改
Tasha: Jake, why don't you come out and change?
其他人：烧好了已经
Others: It's already burned.
Tasha: 哎呀不好意思
Tasha: Oh, sorry about that.
其他人：这不会是你做的吧
Others: This isn't something you made, right?
Shure: 不是不是
Shure: No, no.
Shure: 这怎么可能
Shure: How could that be?
Shure: 这是Logic
Shure: This is Logic.
Shure: 我赶紧把这些膜那个截图都给记下来
Shure: I quickly took screenshots of these membranes.
Shure: 是吧然后到时候证明我的材料对
Shure: Yeah, then I'll use these to prove my materials later.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
其他人：要是我去朋友家他得
Others: If I went to a friend's house and he had
其他人：布置成这样
Others: it set up like this,
其他人：我能在这里呆一天一夜
Others: I could stay here for a day and a night.
其他人：三天三夜
Others: Three days and three nights.
其他人：我们在这里打游戏
Others: We could play games here.
其他人：然后说话
Others: And chat.
Tasha: 是的很适合小蝴蝶在一起说悄悄话
Tasha: Yes, it's perfect for little butterflies to whisper secrets together.
其他人：来自我的战区哈哈
Others: From my war zone, haha.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Tasha: 我吃不下了
Tasha: I can't eat anymore.